the Jo Rogan Experience my dad worked in
the mines for 20 some years oh wow and
you know he's 7071 now and and he's
feeling all that is that where minor
imperfections come from yeah that's a
great song yeah my buddy Zach McCord and
I wrote that for our dads it's a great
song yeah both of our dads are minors
and and that was for him it's a great
song Yeah Yeah there that work is
[__] insane that works insane yeah
that's like when people man we want to
talk about the hard life that's that's
the hard life yeah yeah there when my
dad was my age from from 27 to 30 he
worked in 26 and2 Ines of coal that's
from Florida
ceiling wow and it was for a
small so you know there's coal companies
and then sometimes there just be this
guy that was a land owner back in the
day that would get you know the right
permits and stuff to be able to M A SEMA
coal on some property he'd bought and
that's what the case was with with you
know that job that he had there for 3
years was it was like for a small like
private mind they weren't using roof
bolts oh my God so he had he had cave
ends before where he he was digging his
way crawling on his on his belly trying
to dig his way oh my God yeah he did
that for three years and oh my God and
he had cave-ins like that mhm yeah it's
complet I mean that never fly nowadays
but my dad started in in the he was born
in 53 so he just started in the early
70s and he went into the early 90s so he
was at that unique time where there was
still some of that that old time stuff
and then you know it was transitioning
into the the modern-day Minds you know
today where it's just underground cities
like when he left he was the uh longall
boss at Federal number two for consol
and that was the biggest long wall in
the world at the time and I mean that
that mine it stretches like like over
100 miles underground you know it's from
Western count it's like from Western M
County to damn near the Ohio River like
really yeah and that and and that's a
small that's small compared to what
people are doing now really oh they got
mines in in like Utah where because of
the elevation of the mountains they they
can almost they're they're like Drive
they can drive in to a Sema coold and
automatically be like you know already
10,000 ft underground because of the the
height of the mountain above them and
then it's like 16t seems a coal and and
stuff like that things have gotten you
know the stuff that my dad started out
in is just a thing of the past so when
your dad was doing it he was would you
say 27 in 26 and A2 that's what he told
me and so you just on your back chipping
coal out no they would I mean they would
had Machinery they weren't doing that by
hand but so with Machinery though you're
crawling on your stomach yeah crawling
on your stomach and then how you getting
it out would have been conveyor belts or
something oh my God yeah and you're just
in that
entire enclosed
environment yeah I mean all day long
yeah I would be freaking out if it was
that oh my God and then you're dealing
with cavins yeah oh my God yeah I had no
idea that there's mines that are that
big that are 100 miles oh yeah they're
huge is there photos or videos of those
counties that sounds insane I had no
idea yeah like they they'll keep yeah
from what I understand I think we got
mines in that start in Western M County
and go all the way to like Wetzel County
like over close to the Ohio River
they're huge
wow and and these massive ceilings and
they have lights in there and everything
yeah got you know lights and guys can I
imagine stand like pretty much stand up
have you seen those I don't know how all
the in it they've had fires in them
since like the 50s yeah there's a
there's a town in Pennsylvania I think
that you know there's like a before and
after picture because ended up one like
an old mine ended up Catching Fire and
thing's still like smoking toxic fumes
everybody had to move out of the Town
yeah like 50 60 years later yeah it's
still on fire to this day just like what
like how much Coal's in there yeah um
the fires are too deep to burn and too
hot to be fought effectively 250 years
before what however experts believe the
fires under Centralia could burn another
250 years before they exhaust the coal
Supply that fuels
them wow the fires are too deep and burn
too hot to be fought effectively that's
insane Jamie if you would check uh fact
1962 wow fact check me on like how how
long those Minds can go I was just
trying to figure out where should uh
where should I check for just be like
like long like biggest mins in the world
longest mins just make sure I'm not
talking out of my
ass well it sounds like again I'm a
musician at least they're huge and just
just this this is all knowledge this is
my dad's knowledge that I'm trying to
like spit back out just make sure I'm
not talking larg 10,000 acres whoa yeah
that's pretty big that's miles that's
[__] huge 10,000 acres and it's a
mine hobit mine complex holy [__]
where's that West Virginia I just kep in
West Virginia I'm sure there's there's
the bigger ones in Colorado do they have
uh footage of
that I mean it's going to be a lot
underground so yeah but I'd like to see
it I just want to see what it looks like
10,000 acres of Mines holy [__]
man that's incredible
yeah they got some big ones out in Utah
Alabama's got some big
ones I think Drummond knows those I
would never guessed I would have never
guessed they're that big underground oh
that's a those are strip mines that's
strip mines that's different that's the
like underground coal mine
footage it's a hard life man that's a
hard life yeah and in some places it's
the only thing that's available certain
parts of the country yeah it was it was
a great opportunity for my dad you know
it allowed him to to you know Elevate
himself economically and does he have
lung problems because of it no no no he
didn't no he was I think starting in the
early 70s I think they they figured a
lot of that out oh yeah yeah I don't
think it's it was as bad then as it was
you know back in the the 50s and
before yeah I don't think he has any uh
like long-term issues you know steril
has a lot of people in his family that
came from that too it's like there's
that is just a different understanding
of hard work and and of poverty too I
mean the people that that when those
Minds shut down that's another sort of
similar example those Minds if they shut
down the whole town relies on those
minds and there's nothing mhm yeah yeah
you got ghost towns West Virginia mhm
got um did you ever read the book Rocket
Boys no by Homer hickham then they made
the movie October Sky about it did you
ever watch that no what is it dude it's
a it's an
incredible here Bailey mine look at that
machine holy [__] there you go
yeah that's about and what is what
causes
coal it's vegetation and pressure over
millions of years isn't it is that what
it is I think wow
wow look at this [__] life man
underground just using machines to cut
out chunks of the earth that people
going to light on fire and then most
people want to ban that [__] anyway but
meanwhile China we're just looking at
how many like when people are talking
about we got to stop people from eating
meat to save the planet [__] you need
to pay attention to the world cuz most
of that shit's coming from China there's
more than a thousand coal mines in China
yeah there's more tonnage of coal being
mined now than ever before in in
history you know
that's yeah yeah it's a complicated
world with a lot of like really
narrow-minded narratives like a really a
lot of confusing things that people
repeat that they don't really understand
the the whole depth to what they're
saying yeah you could close down all the
mines in the United States and that
demand for that coal is still going to
be there and it'll just get mind
somewhere else yeah it's not to say that
maybe you know there'll come a day where
coal probably becomes a thing of the
past and isn't used anymore but probably
once they run out of it yeah once they
once they run out of it or you know they
think of something better but it's just
you know it just and then we're going to
have to deal with earthquakes and sink
holes cuz they're going [__] carve
these huge [__] Pockets out of the
earth and things are going to collapse
yeah yeah they you know at the end of
the day if that's not going to that's
not going to solve The World's problem s
if they just shut all that down in the
US overnight I watched a video of a coal
mine collapsing in China and it was
horrifying my friend Tom sigur and I we
uh every day we send each other the
worst [__] we find on Instagram it's
it's very traumatizing it's like I'll
show it to you on my phone after the
podcast is over you're going to go what
the [__] man every day every day we send
each other car accidents gunshots animal
attacks over and over and O every day
every day some new [__] yeah and um one
of them was this insane coal explo this
is it this is it so these people are
working and then this oh my God yeah
they just get
engulfed open pit Coal Mine
collapsed four people injured six
missing 49 others
yeah guess where 53 folks they're dead
they might be missing they're dead
massive
Landslide wow yeah well that's mean
you're digging into the [__] ground
and creating
instability scary [__] yeah yeah that's
that's that's insane yeah the people
want to stop coal mining like yeah I
understand but you have to understand
how much of that is going on outside
this
country